lors de cette visite officielle les
autorités françaises ont opté pour un
format sobre en adéquation avec la crise
sanitaire liée en couronne à virus
au programme de ces quelques heures à
l'elysée un tête à tête entre emmanuel
macron écailles sayed un point de presse
commun et un dîner officiel
le président français qui a profité de
cette tribune face aux médias pour
rappeler l'urgence en libye tout en
critiquant directement le comportement
de la turquie
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire très
clairement président r dogan je
considère aujourd'hui que la turquie
joue en libye
un jeu dangereux et contrevient à tous
ses engagements pris lors de la
conférence de berlin
la joute verbale entre paris et ankara
semble le plus c'est cette s'accélérer
les deux s'accusent mutuellement de
contribuer à la dégradation de la
situation sécuritaire en libye
lors de son discours emmanuel macron est
également revenu sur les récents
incidents navals qui ont opposé la
france et la turquie en méditerranée
objet d'une enquête à l'otan j'ai noté
qu à l inverse la turquie s'était
réengagé contrairement à ce qu'elles
s'étaient ce qu'elle nous avait promis
c'est un fait il est documenté et
lorsque je regarde ce qui a été fait la
semaine dernière sous commandement otan
au large de la libye considère que c'est
inacceptable et je vous renvoie mes
déclarations de la fin d'année dernière
sur la mort cérébrale de l'otan je
considère que c'est l'une des plus
belles démonstrations qui soit et une
crainte d'une mort cérébrale de l'otan
que le président français avait déjà
exprimé fin 2019
une expression reprise alors de façon
très virulente par le président turc qui
demandait à emmanuel macron je cite de
faire examiner sa propre mort cérébrale
au-delà de cette guerre des mots
l'instabilité et l'insécurité en libye
inquiètent toute une région et en
particulier la tunisie qui possède une
frontière de 460 km avec la libye alors
déjà il faut une constitution provisoire
est une organisation provisoire et avec
le président la conseillère allemande
mama marqueur tout que j'ai rencontrés
avec quelqu'un que j'ai abordé la
situation libyenne j'ai dit que les
choses pouvaient voir se poursuivre
ainsi la tunisie est l'un des pays qui
souffrent le plus de cette situation de
la france aussi pour des morceaux phares
est également en pâtir
tunis a toujours fait la neutralité un
principe en matière de politique
étrangère et ce malgré le conflit libyen
qui pèsent sur la stabilité politique et
économique de la tunisie
[Musique]